et on en revient ce qu'on voit des
libertés à ottawa au canada ce week-end
un mouvement de contestation des
camionneurs contre les mesures
sanitaires une grogne similaire
peut-elle arriver en europe en france on
en parle tout de suite avec notre
éditorialiste nicolas vidal c l'édito
politique de la matinale
[Musique]
nicolas vidal bonjour bonjour olivier
heureux de vous retrouver ce matin dans
la matinale d'arte france et cette
semaine on commence à parler du convoi
de la liberté des routiers au canada
bien entendu alors oui vous venez de le
dire no magic olivier laliberté à la
liberté je me souviens d'avoir appris ce
magnifique poème de paul eluard sur les
bancs de l'école primaire qui disait je
cite sur mes cahiers d'écoliers sur mon
pupitre et les arbres sur le sable et
sur la neige j'écris ton nom mais comme
je suis un éternel sentimentale un peu
rétro je m'accroche et des trucs du
passé un peu poussiéreux des trucs qu'on
a plus l'habitude de voir l utiliser
alors pour préparer cet édito je suis
allé voir la définition de ce vieux mot
français dans le dictionnaire et on peut
lire que la liberté je cite et la
situation d'une personne qui n'est pas
une dépendance de quelqu'un ou qui n'est
pas enfermé c'est aussi la possibilité
pouvoir d'agir sans contraintes
alors quand j'ai entendu parler du
combat la liberté il ya plus d'une
semaine au canada je me suis dit mais
qu'est ce qu'ils sont has been ces
canadiens valeur qu'on veut la liberté
pourquoi ne pas avoir fait tout
simplement un avenir sur tito qu'une
touriste reste à g depuis la cabine et
leurs camions ça c'est moderne c'est
jeune c'est dynamique et puis cela
aurait beaucoup plu à justin mais comme
ils ont voulu faire ça à l'ancienne avec
des drapeaux des blocages et que
l'action est bien justin trudeau n'a pas
apprécié et donc il est allé se cacher
très fâché dans un chalet en famille
pour soigner seront microns mais plus
sérieusement le congolais est ouverte au
canada nous dit beaucoup sur l'époque
pré totalitaire que nous vivons dans
nombreux pays et malgré ça les médias
meanstream qui commence un petit peu en
parlent et analyse ce mouvement dans des
termes peu reluisant il en parle comme
d'un convoi anti vague très très très
minoritaire composé essentiellement de
l'idu radicaux suprémacistes et
accessoirement bas du front mais la
réalité est tout autre olivier alors
justement nicolas qu'est ce que nous
disent ce convoi de la liberté de
l'époque actuelle
pb nous dit que la folie sanitaire est
devenu l'alibi parfait de quelques pays
dits libéraux pour imposer une société
de surveillance et de contrôle est ce
qu'on veut la liberté au canada et le
premier coup de boutoir contre une doxa
politique et médiatique officiel qui est
en train de s'écrouler avec fracas ces
milliers de canadiens qui ont souffert
comme nom du coc vide des mesures
sanitaires et d'enfin d'un contrôle
généralisé des populations manifestent
des filets le monde à récupérer leur
liberté en réalité ils réclament
simplement le droit de vivre comme des
femmes et des hommes libres alors non il
n'est pas acceptable de traiter ces
milliers de gens comme de la frange du
canada non il n'est pas acceptable dans
l'enfer des extravagants anti vaccin
anti progrès anti-science y est anti
démocratie non il n'est plus acceptable
d'en faire des sous citoyens comme l'a
dit justin trudeau et comme l'a aussi
fait manuel macron il n'y ait plus
entendable aujourd'hui mes amis ni au
canada ni en france ni nulle part
ailleurs de conditionner la vaccination
médicamenteuse à la citoyenneté à la
dignité et à la liberté et ce qui est
effrayée entre le canada la france c'est
cette funeste rhétorique politique qui
était imposé à tous les citoyens et ce
même traitement médiatique à charge une
directrice d'une sélection info en bout
et récemment qu'il ne fallait pas aller
contre la parole officielle pour éviter
de désagréger le consensus social mais
si ce consensus social c'est la
servitude volontaire de tout un pays à
la perte de liberté et l'acceptation que
les devoirs serait supérieure à nos
droits cela venu dire que nous sommes en
train de sombrer dans un avenir
effrayant aussi bien au canada qu'en
france alors ce qu'on veut la liberté
c'est le mouvement puissant nomme peuple
qui ne veut pas voir mourir ses libertés
les plus fondamentales et qui demande de
vivre dignement et le réduire à une
procession de complotiste d'extrémistes
est une erreur voire mensonges les
villes et le coville le convoi de la
liberté au canada pourrait-il se
propager en france et en europe c'est
très probable au vu de l'émulation
incroyable sur télégramme et facebook
depuis quelques jours des citoyens
français excédés par ce que nous vivons
tente d'organiser en qu'on veut la
liberté dès la semaine prochaine est ce
que ça sera suivie et massif personne
n'en sait rien pas même les
organisateurs ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya un mouvement
l'échelle européenne qui tente
d'organiser des convois pour arriver le
14 février à bruxelles quelques article
paru dans certains médias français on
parle comme d'un convoi d'anti vax
rejoints par des gilets jaunes écrire
cela c'est refuser de voir ce qu'il se
passe et ne pas vouloir comprendre ou
alors allez aveuglément dans le sens de
la parole officielle car ces médias nous
refont le même pdg les gens dans leur
temps car ils ont le peuple les émotions
populaires en horreur surtout lorsqu'on
sont légitimes et la question
fondamentale qui se pose aujourd'hui est
ce matin est la suivante que reste si la
sémillante france et insulté par
emmanuel macron pour crier leur colère
face est discriminatoire
mis à chanter ta que nous vivons voter
pour une petite poignée de
parlementaires après trois ans de
manifestations il ne leur reste que la
rue les départementales et nationales
pour se faire entendre et hannah arendt
écrivait je cite les mouvements
totalitaires sont des organisations
mincir ou d'individus atomisés isolé et
bien justement ces français épris de
liberté font preuve d'une solidarité
incroyable désormais les autres pour
tenter de sauver notre démocratie notre
avenir et notre liberté à tous olivier
merci nicolas l'édito politique de
nicolas vidal a retrouvé bien évidemment
sur les réseaux sociaux